when you were going to college or
whatever they left places you know where
weird works like I just didn't I just
yeah what's his name the guy that lifts
it yeah
so they'd sit you in the front no they
didn't no way are you talking about here
I gotta play a clip hey listen to this
this is Bradley when he was a student in
the front row Sean Penn was the front
end let's relive this you know you're a
little too full of yourself let's we
should beg let's take you down a peg
you're going out you're in that College
inside the actor studio right yeah nht
and and Sean Penn is they sector on
stage and here you are my name is
Bradley Cooper I'm a second-year actor
my questions regarding hurly-burly what
was it like to revisit a character Eddie
after a 10-year hiatus did you have new
discoveries did you find it it was a
different approach because you had
already done this character before did
you have that written out like Bobo like
the guy falls into my it was not off the
couch not off the cover you had that
written down I have it written down but
before the hand I need the mic I was so
nervous about really like to revisit a
character I just remember after 10 year
I ate is did you did you care about the
answer or were you sitting there going
hey I got to get on camera somehow it
was there is no that never aired oh we
didn't know they'd only aired it after I
think I started to do well as an actor
oh I show that because I didn't do this
thing I think we you had to say like I'm
an actor I'm in the acting tract I'm in
the third year and I just never just go
right to the I think I'm saying Brad can
act then I would just ask the question
you weren't hand-selected ahead of time
god no this was not you raise your hand
if you have a question and then they
they ask it yeah I didn't want to I was
terrified up Sean Penn or a fighter like
first of all like it's a television show
I actually took a long time to be
comfortable in front of big audiences
right when I was a kid I was terrified
to do anything like that so I really did
want to know right because I thought it
was interesting it just made this movie
right and I was just working on the
scene that he had done the play of years
ago right so I wanted to ask him but
everything inside me said just shut up
and don't ask him anything